bootlegate podcast special guests in
here representing Phoenix Arizona
what part of the [ __ ] Jay what uh uh
West Side bro Maryville we was over in
that area you know what I'm saying so
shout out to all my [ __ ] on the west
big love everybody shout out to the West
Side man Maryville
[ __ ] one of them areas one is
probably the area
oh God oh God you know if you know you
know you know what I'm saying [ __ ] yeah
man Miracles my [ __ ] his nieces
quinceanera was at Maryvale she's from
Mesa I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
having a [ __ ] over here for it was cheap
of course it was it wasn't Mary but
we're all gonna die over here hey bro
that's where all the heart you know what
I'm saying and all the culture is you
know love Maryville great place uh
anyway listen man you've been doing your
thing
um shout out just real quick before we
have you do your your you know you're
gonna get your bars off but like what do
you got going on promote your music uh
so right now I'm actually about to drop
an EP on the 17th of this month called
so it seems fire uh yeah we about to get
that out the way we've been having a
crazy year I dropped the album called
corduroy earlier this year
um and yeah we're just trying to keep
[ __ ] going trying to keep [ __ ] uh
rocking man you know so we got music
coming out all the time corduroy 1017
and you know I'm gonna keep everybody
posted corduroys I thought you said
corduroy already came out corduroy came
out my bad nah yeah so it seems so
they're all surprise
yes 10 17. so it seems that's what's
happening there it is boom and you know
what this will this by the time you see
this it'll already be out it's out right
now it's out right now go listen to that
[ __ ] yeah that shit's like a week and a
half away this is definitely coming out
in like two weeks so go listen to that
[ __ ] go stream it man let's get to it yo
hit the beat Cyrus
let's go yeah
[Music]
check hey heavy as they head there with
a crown that's what they telling me
jumping off the porch I'm everything
that I said I be putting on for moosey
[ __ ] is spooky if a hollow ring
Halloween body thing smell it in the air
like a pot of greens but no cat this
just rap Hells I'm supposed to quote
that when everything you spit is like a
pistol with the blowback what's up to
all my [ __ ] living life on the land
your mic is in hand but they don't give
a [ __ ] what you saying say I didn't been
way at the bottom it's a gift in the
curse but giving a verse the [ __ ] it or
this shifting to work but let me get
back to these Graphics putting [ __ ] on
shirts this cephalus raps Boy tell me
where the veterans at you better than
that well bag it I'm delivering crack
they double him back then Franklin
saying can devil in rap minimal contact
[ __ ] ain't got heated numbers deleted
are you calm yet talk like you got it
look in his wallet are you on yet [ __ ]
in your chest better invest they move
upon yet [ __ ] is too easy better believe
me peep my palm next they couldn't read
it never could see it that's just
context cause y'all gave me reason Paige
is just bleeding cause I'm on next [ __ ]
I'm gonna do it like I'm supposed to I'm
showing [ __ ] different making flips up
off the Pro Tools if [ __ ] want to
smoke this that Emissions on the old
school we never give them passes kick
their asses if they roll through uh
bootleg tell these [ __ ] step it up
because I do think I'm the best I just
never address it much but let's talk a
lot of [ __ ] muddy [ __ ] in the dark
came in the circuit hella late but still
I came with a spark the brightest future
consumer proven they never lose it
already know it the [ __ ] is easy enjoy
the music stupid I'm killing [ __ ] with
all my uploads and [ __ ] I'm independent
on my Masters on an iPhone [ __ ] I'm
done like let's go let's go
[Music]
Maryvale
Phoenix Arizona [ __ ] Jay Watt
hey you just watched a crazy freestyle
and we drop one every week sometimes
more than once a week and they're always
presented by our family at LRG now I
love LRG I'm wearing look I'm gonna just
show you the new shorts I got from them
check out them shorts my boy you know
what I'm saying and got the plain black
tea the plain black lrgt you know what I
mean listen lrg's back they just dropped
the crazy Jason hoodie with Jadakiss
that's from like 2008 for Halloween
[ __ ] Flames go to the website
l-r-g.com and this is crazy because
they're giving you 30 off when you use
the promo code bootleg 30 percent off
that's a significant amount of money
you're going to be saving when you go to
lrg's website Christmas is coming save
30 off just by going to the website and
using the promo code bootleg L Dash R
g.com we'll see you next week with a
crazy freestyle